- Manhattan District Attorney Cy Vance
has convened a special grand jury
to hear evidence about potential charges
against members of the Trump Organization,
and potentially the Trump family.
Reached for comment,
the former president said,
"Absolutely everyone says my
juries are the grandest juries
anyone has ever seen.
Big, beautiful juries the likes of which
no one has ever seen.
My juries are at least
100 grand, everyone says."
So, what is a grand
jury in the first place?
And is Donald Trump really
in trouble this time or what?
Well, it kinda.
- [Advertiser] Sponsored by Ting Mobile.
- Hey, LegalEagles.
It's time to think like
a District Attorney.
Now, what are the
responsibilities of grand jurors?
How much influence does
the prosecutor have?
And what is the situation
for Trump and his employees?
Today, we're gonna learn the ins and outs
of the grand jury process in New York.
But the first question is,
"How easy is it to indict
someone with a grand jury?"
Well, former New York State
Chief Judge Sol Wachtler
once said the prosecutors
had so much control
over the grand jury that by and large,
they could get them to
indict a ham sandwich.
Now this phrase has become shorthand
for prosecutors' ability
to get grand juries
to do whatever they want.
And as we'll discuss
later on in this video,
that control can go both ways.
And ironically, Wachtler
himself was later indicted
for hush money payments to a mistress.
But back to the story at hand,
what is going on with Trump?
Well, the Washington Post reported that
a Manhattan grand jury had
recently started to meet
to review potential charges
against the Trump organization
and its principles.
So this information is not entirely new.
Vance's office has been investigating the
Trump organization for about two years.
We don't know all of the
details, but tax fraud
and campaign finance violations
are both on the table.
Former Trump lawyer, Michael Cohen,
has been interviewed eight times
by Vance's office.
And Cohen has discussed
hush money payments
he allegedly made to Trump's mistresses.
In addition to providing background
on how Trump's businesses were operated.
Last year, I did a video about the
explosive allegations of Trump tax fraud
by the New York Times.
Vance's office as believed to
be looking at whether Trump
or his employees lied
about the value of assets
to gain favorable loan
terms and tax benefits.
Vance's investigation got
a boost earlier this year
after the Supreme Court ruled that Trump
had to turn over eight
years of tax records.
Reports say that these
records include both the final
and draft version of tax returns.
And this information
would be central to any
determination that Trump
himself had criminal liability
especially with regards
to his mental state
when these financial documents were filed.
And as we discussed in the
video about Trump's taxes,
it's not easy to prove tax fraud.
Tax fraud turns on whether
the person filing the return
knew that they were committing fraud.
Powerful people like CEOs and Mob Bosses
are usually pretty savvy
about speaking in code
and shifting responsibility
to others in the hierarchy,
like Cohen or CFO of
the Trump organization,
Allen Weisselberg, for instance.
I mean we don't know what
is actually happening
inside the Trump
organization at this time.
But that's why we should be wary
about drawing from conclusions about
whether the grand jury
will find evidence that
Trump had an intent to commit crimes.
But it is a possibility.
So the question is,
"What is this grand jury
that's looking at Trump
actually doing right now?"
Well, first we have to start
with what is a grand jury?
A grand jury is a group of citizens
who must decide whether
there's enough evidence
for a person to be charged with a crime.
It's a very different proceeding than
the jury trials you're
probably used to seeing on TV.
So, let's start with the difference
between a petit jury and a grand jury.
A Petit Jury is convened to decide
whether someone has committed a crime
or a defendant has civil liability.
Petit juries listened to
the evidence presented
by both parties during a trial,
and then return a verdict.
If a Petit jury finds the defendant guilty
then there'll be sentenced typically
with a fine imprisonment
or combination of both.
A Petit jury is the jury
that you're probably
used to seeing on TV.
In contrast, a grand jury does not
determine someone's guilt or innocence.
It also has no involvement in civil cases.
This is a purely criminal issue.
A grand jury hears evidence
presented by a prosecutor
that jury must determine
whether there is probable cause to believe
that the person or entity
has committed a crime.
If the grand jury decides
that there is probable cause,
then it will file a written
statement of a charge.
This is called an "indictment".
If the grand jury finds
probable cause then,
the defendant will be
formally charged with a crime.
And potentially there will
be an actual criminal trial
to determine their guilt or innocence.
Now this isn't the way that it happens
in every case or in every state.
Some states use what's
called an information
which is basically just
an indictment that comes
directly from the District Attorney
with no need for the
involvement of a grand jury.
But let's talk about New York law.
In the New York constitution,
Article 1 Section 6 says that,
"No defendant may be tried
for a felony without the case
first having been
presented to a grand jury."
A New York grand jury is composed
of between 23 and 16 people.
These people are summoned
the same way that
anyone is for jury duty, with
a notice from a County Clerk.
The jurors usually have to serve a term
that ranges from between two
weeks and several months.
And a special grand jury can
meet for up to six months.
And since this proceeding doesn't
determine someone's guilt,
it only determines whether there's
probable cause for an indictment.
You don't have a lot of the safeguards
that you would normally have
in a full blown criminal trial.
For example, under New York
law, there's no judge presiding
in the room during the
grand jury proceedings.
The prosecutor's in charge
and is therefore responsible
for presenting the government's case
and reading the law to the grand jury.
This means that Cy Vance's
office has two roles.
First, presenting evidence
as a District Attorney for Manhattan
and advising the grand jury about process.
The DA takes on the role of a judge
by advising the jury and ruling on the
admissibility of evidence
and answering questions.
Hopefully the DA will act in good faith
but if he believes that
there's probable cause,
he's going to present evidence
advocating for an indictment.
This is why grand juries are so one-sided.
So, who is in this
secretive grand jury room?
Well, usually it's the jurors,
the prosecutor, and a court reporter.
Witnesses are only
present during questioning
the defendant and his or her lawyers
are generally not present
but will get to an exception to that.
And when the jury deliberates,
the prosecutors and court
reporter leave the room.
Grand jurors can ask questions
which is something that doesn't happen
during criminal trial proceedings.
However, the prosecutor
then puts on the judge hat
and decides whether the
question is relevant.
And in a federal grand jury, yes,
the federal prosecutors are
bound by a similar procedure.
The prosecutor is not constrained
by the rules of evidence that applied
during the criminal trial.
But in New York, the prosecutor
is bound by the state's
rules of evidence with a
few noteworthy exceptions
which give more leeway
for hearsay testimony.
If someone is indicted
based on hearsay testimony,
prosecutors will then have to develop
non-hearsay evidence
for the criminal case.
Now, I know this sounds
incredibly one sided,
but remember, there's still a
criminal trial get to happen.
This is only deciding about a
potential indictment and traditionally,
a potential defendant
had no right to testify
in his or her defense in
front of a grand jury.
But, defendants in New
York do have a right to
testify before the grand jury.
But, this is almost never a good idea
because the bar is so
low to get an indictment.
For example, New York
criminal procedure law
Section 190.50 provides
that a potential defendant
must be permitted to
testify before a grand jury.
But, the potential defendant has to sign
and submit a waiver of
immunity and a waiver of his
or her fifth amendment right
against self-incrimination.
And there's very little benefit
to testifying before a grand jury.
A potential defendant
won't know the extent
of the government's case against them.
And unlike a criminal trial process
where the evidence has established
well in advance of trial.
And the prosecutor has
an obligation to give
that evidence to the defendants.
Here, the person's testimony could tip off
the prosecutor about additional
evidence and witnesses.
And potentially worst
of all, the defendant's
testimony could also be used
in a future criminal trial.
Meaning that the evidence
the person blindly offers
during a grand jury proceeding
could be highly damning and
used against them in the future.
Believe me, former
President Trump does not
want to testify before any grand jury.
Even though, as I'm sure he would say
the testimony would be
beautiful, perfect testimony.
And perhaps most importantly
at the conclusion
of the proceedings, jurors will vote
on whether there is probable cause
that the potential
defendant committed a crime.
They vote on whether to return
what is called a "true bill"
authorizing prosecutors
to indict the defendant.
And in the grand jury,
prosecutors don't need
a unanimous grand jury
and affirmative vote
of just 12 grand jurors
is enough to authorize an indictment.
And if 12 jurors don't believe
enough evidence exists to charge a person,
then they can return
what's called a "no bill"
which prevents indictment
but, that's pretty unlikely.
But either way, everything
related to the proceeding
is supposed to just to
be sealed and secret,
which is interesting given that there were
leaks with it led to the Washington Post
reporting that the grand jury exists
and is in process.
But let's talk about secrecy
in these grand jury proceedings.
Both state and federal grand juries
are conducted in secrecy.
The Supreme COurt has laid out
many reasons for secret proceedings.
Number 1, prevents the
escape potential defendants.
It ensures that the
jurors are not pressured
by their friends or
threatened with retaliation
by potential defendants.
It discourages perjury and encourages
people to testify without fear.
And it protects potential defendants
who are not yet indicted
from the disclosure
that they were investigated for a crime.
Under New York law,
the prosecutor and jurors are
not allowed to reveal anything
about the presentation,
including testimony or voting.
It's a felony to disclose
grand jury information.
However, the secrecy
doesn't extend to witnesses.
So, the hundred thousand dollars question,
"Is an indictment against members
of the Trump family imminent?"
Well, a few words of caution about reports
that Donald Trump is about to be indicted.
First of all, Donald
Trump is potentially not
the only target of this probe.
He may not even be a target of this probe.
Officers of the company, Don Jr.
And CFO Allen Weisselberg
could be implicated
as could Ivanka or Trump sisters.
And of course, in a similarly
analogous situation,
people over-invested in
the Mueller investigation
only to be let down
when Mueller interpreted
his mandate very, very narrowly.
Saying that he wasn't
allowed to say whether
Trump committed a crime or not
which is a source of great
controversy to this day.
And Cy Vance is not exactly
Captain America either.
In January 2020, advocates
called on Vance to
resign because of his pattern of allowing
wealthy and powerful
defendants off the hook.
Vance declined to prosecute
Harvey Weinstein in 2015.
He also allegedly bungled a case
against OB GYN, Robert Hadden,
who allegedly abused dozens of patients.
Vance arrested Hadden in 2012,
but his arrest was voided
and he was allowed to continue practicing.
Evelyn Yang, the wife of
New York mayoral candidate
Andrew Yang, said that she
was one of Hadden's victims
and she's blasted Vance along with
many of the other victims, as well.
Now, sources didn't exactly say how long
the grand jury has been meeting.
A special grand jury proceeding
last for no longer than six months.
If recently means they
started a few weeks ago,
then we could be waiting several months
before anything happens.
If we ever see anything at all.
If they started to meet five months ago,
an indictment or not, might be a minute.
Though, that seems unlikely.
However, if you're looking for clues
consider that it was just last week
that we learned that New York
Attorney General, Tish James,
now has two lawyers working with
the Manhattan district attorney.
It's relatively unusual for the
Attorney General's office to team up
with the local district attorney.
They're often turf wars and apparently
that's not happening here.
And the revelation came
right after James announced
that the state's civil investigation
of the Trump organization has evolved
into a criminal matter.
We don't know why it's criminal
but it may have something
to do with evidence
that was developed during the ongoing
Manhattan grand jury process.
But remember, I mentioned
that it's often extremely
easy to manipulate the grand
jury process by prosecutors.
That also means the
prosecutors can manipulate it
in the other direction,
away from an indictment
if that's what they want to do.
If they would actually
prefer not to indict someone.
And we've already seen
this in many police cases,
such as the case involving
the death of Breonna Taylor.
Kentucky Attorney General, Daniel Cameron,
is in hot water for allegedly lying
about what he presented to a grand jury
and allegedly sandbagging
his own efforts to
procure an indictment in that case.
But, it certainly looks like Vance
wants to indict someone.
But we can't assume anything right now
including the identity of that person.
Vance announced that he's stepping down
at the end of the year, which
is kind of a strange move
for someone who was about to bring the
highest profile case
of his entire lifetime.
But at the end of the day,
if you have personally
witnessed illegal activity
by the Trump organization or its members
you should call the authorities.
And you can save money on that call by
switching to Ting Mobile.
I personally switched to Ting Mobile
and have saved literally
hundreds of dollars a month.
I'm not kidding here.
Why?
Because of this.
Yes, that is a real cell
phone bill that I got
with my previous provider.
And it's why I personally
switched to Ting.
And Ting Mobile has three brand new plans
to make sure that this
never happens again.
All of Ting's plans have
unlimited talk and text
starting at just $10 per month.
Add data for as little as $5 per gigabyte,
or choose a set of data
or just go full unlimited for $45 a month.
Switching plans is really, really easy
because you can keep
your same phone number
and use pretty much any phone.
And the service is great too
because Ting partners with
several massive networks.
Probably the very same one
that you're using right now,
but at a huge discount.
They literally use the
same infrastructure.
Now, actually, I can't tell you which ones
because I always respect contracts.
But let's just say that my
service hasn't changed at all.
And it's incredibly
easy to transfer service
using the exact same phone
number you have right now.
You just order a Ting SIM
card, pop it in and set it up.
You don't even have to call anyone.
It's like magic.
So if you go to legaleagle.ting.com
or click on the link in the description,
you can use your last bill to compare
just how much you would save.
And LegalEagles will also get a $25
service credit that could
cover two months of service.
So just click on the link
in the description and give it a try.
Plus, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
So, do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this other
LegalEagle video right here.
I think you're really going to like it.
So click on this video
or I'll see you in court.